parties here
and prices here the two big challenges
facing the prime minister
for now clarity on both issues in short
supply
this cabinet minister unable to say who
organized a meeting between boris
johnson and sue gray the senior civil
servant investigating lockdown breaches
sugue's first report didn't pull its
punches who called the meeting you know
that the prime minister
would never intervene in such a uh
investigation has not intervened has
allowed it to happen sue grace
you can't question sugar's integrity
because i've worked with superintendent
you're not questioning her integrity
very very simple you will factor you as
i i one i don't know two i don't know
what's in the report is boris johnson
off the hook sugray's team have been
contacting people this weekend who will
potentially be named in the report and
giving them a chance to raise concerns
labour says it still trusts the
investigator she is a civil servant of
the highest integrity we don't know the
details of that meeting
it's not clear who called it there's
different accounts of that so it's hard
for me to say what was said there
but i do have faith in her integrity and
let's see what she says when the report
comes out the working assumption among
tory mps here is that boris johnson will
have an ugly 48 hours when the sugray
report is published but will ultimately
survive it arguably what's playing on
their minds more now is the spiraling
cost of living and the apparent lack of
plan in government to help people cope
the possibility of a windfall tax on the
profits of oil and gas companies has not
been ruled out by the treasury with the
sunday times reporting a version of the
levy is on the table where there will be
lower rates if firms invested more
energy bosses say recent price rises are
unprecedented we are seeing a
significant number of people in fuel
poverty that's to say more than 10 of
their disposable income spent on energy
and that's risen to around 20
and in october
our model suggests that that could rise
to 40 percent if the government doesn't
intervene in some way
so where are the cabinet on the idea the
chancellor hasn't ruled it out saying
he's not naturally attracted to it but
is pragmatic others are more critical
today the northern ireland secretary
said it wouldn't really work the health
secretary said yesterday i instinctively
don't like it last week the business
secretary said he was against that type
of tax and last month the justice
secretary said it would damage
investment and be disastrous
i don't think the next election will be
about partygate i think it will be
fought on which party has the best
long-term plans for the economy for
the nhs i think the core reasons that
people vote conservative which is
the prospect of strong economic growth
the prospect of lower taxes
these things are not true at the moment
after smoldering for months the
partygate scandal will reach a
flashpoint this week but its cost of
living that may ultimately ignite the
bigger row rob powell sky news in
westminster